ich kenne das andere und es ist hart ich
kenne das alles ist einfach scheiß drauf
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
und audiotechnik und wir haben heute
eine richtig coole und originelle church
dabei die uns zur teambesprechung aus
und das letzte video geschrieben hat max
es auch mit dabei übrigens und die
besagt dass man im ganzen jump'n'run
dass wir jetzt machen werden nur fünf
checkpoints mitnehmen da jetzt fragt ihr
euch wie kann es geht dass man den job
dran das aus zehn checkpoints besteht
beendet ohne dass alle zehn ausgelöst
werden und das geht folgendermaßen man
läuft einfach nicht auf die komplette
ihr seht ihr die druckplatten fühlen
nicht den ganzen block aus und so kann
man hier ist ganz besonders aber wenn
die druckplatten im block nicht ganz
ausfüllen kann man auch wenn er nur ein
blog ist wenn man ganz ganz außen am
rand läuft die challenge schaffen und
die komplette nicht auslösen
es ist riskant aber weil man dann wenn
ich jetzt unter falle werde ich nicht da
ein zurückgeworfen
sondern da hinten hin weil ich nicht
gespeichert habe aber das ist die
challenge sehr sehr riskant sehr
schwierig die obergrenze für die check
point sich mitnehmen
bis 5 und wenn ich sechs sieben oder
acht check points mitnehme dann werde
ich bestraft und zwar wie für jeden blog
den ich mitnehme über die fünf erlaubten
hinaus gibt es eine stelle von magna in
straight to face so aber hast du schon
wie ihre nicht mit denen habe ich mich
aber ich nehme die zeit dass es sicherer
leute ich muss ja auch speicher punkte
mitnehmen
ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt hier sicher
durchkomme und dann zwei module
zurückgeworfen zu werden ist dann kostet
war jedoch zu riskant unmengen anfang ja
das kostet unmengen an zeiten es geht
einfach nicht aber die change macht mega
box sehr gute idee von zarti würde ich
mal die oh gott das wird schwierig das
wird richtig schwierig die oja wolle
junge jawohl
die würde ich mal die sprengfallen
challenge nennen so nach dem motto die
druckplatte darauf ist die truppe die
eine sprengfalle ausgelöst
deswegen muss man sich unbedingt
vermeiden und das ist ein wo du da kann
man auch schon mal fehler machen hier
programm ok go up kommt vor allem aus
dem jugendalter
meine nerven die cic ist auf jeden fall
richtig geil dankeschön ans ort so und
wenn ihr auch so originelle change ideen
habt die sind einfach cooler als
irgendwie abwechselt change oder so was
man so was auch nicht schlecht aber
sowas ist wirklich originell und das
kann man nur ein job machen und ja danke
dafür
sehr schön ok 1 millionen abos peschl
wenn es irgendwann soweit kommt da musst
du eine runde die komplette und komplett
gespielt hat eine rolle die komplette
aber die nämlich auch mit denen ich auch
mit ich habe hier 333 ich habe drei oder
zwei nach dem dritten zum ersten mal
geschäft mit zwei sagen wir ich habe
drei deutsche hat mitgezählt
ihr wisst jetzt ob jetzt sind oder
einfach dumm und nicht auf 33 stück 34
ja doch so kommerziell also 30
mitgenommen heißt ich habe noch zwei
freie checkpoints ab dann gibt es
schellen und das hier ist richtig
schwierig sage ich okay aber das ist
auch so schwer von der obenauf
ich war schon ziemlich weit außen aber
es hat nicht ganz gereicht
es ist das modul sind jetzt richtig
prima außerdem scheider ja es ist hart
aber ich werde einfach versuchen die
nächsten blöcke einfach nicht mit seinem
mann der veränderten politiker werden
ich muss sich halt vorher darauf
konzentrieren sieht so ungewohnt
außerdem schwebt dieses modul noch nie
mit schneider gespielt jetzt halt echt
er musste ewig laufen ok es läuft aber
eigentlich ganz gut
und draußen und safe lock unser
checkpoint willst du dir nehmen
ich will nicht nehmen nein ich will es
ist mein 23 minuten spielzeit vor dem
ich will nicht nehmen nein ausgelöst
seht ihr wie weit ihre noch so weit raus
laufen können und millimeter oh mann oh
mann aber ich bin weiter leute ich geb
gas ich werde jetzt nicht aus angst vor
werde nicht aus angst langsam machen das
ist mir egal ich stecke ich weg machen
vollgas aller und zwar so sollte man bei
dem ich mich da ich kann nicht selben
dorf naaldwijk seiten stelle
was kommt da oben ich kenne das andere
nicht mag ich sie durch ich kenne das
andere nicht wahr
ich kenne das andere und es ist hart war
ich schon ich kenne das andere das ist
okay die muss jetzt noch wegstecken
dann gucken wir jetzt noch zu spielen
egal wessen wir noch finnischen würden
wir sind auf einer höhe mit unseren
kontrahenten hier
nein das ist denn das aber glück gehabt
es bringt nichts das ist einer der
tricks um die ecke auf eine leiter aber
das hat 180 grad um die ecke
wer aber hat sich hat sich gelohnt leute
ständig wer ich bin mega oft schmutter
gefallen also zwar verliere ich die
entscheidung und ich kenne das wo du ja
auch deswegen wusste ich dass kann ich
doch ja das war komisch aus weil der
schüler sich geladen und zwar was man
hier gegen sprechen normalerweise kennt
sogar bisher gerade immer
schwierig sei hier drüben ist die kiste
jetzt bist du dran springen gerne oder
lassen sich beim block nummer suchen
springt ja richtig tricky gemacht wieder
okay wisse was als 20 sekunden
ja ich war ich wollte doppel job und ich
konnte auf dem hinteren boxen bisschen
rausnehmen ort ist wo man aber wir haben
es ziemlich weit geschafft
also was zu essen ich jetzt nicht gerade
eben noch gesprochen und sowie ob drauf
macht 96 94 gewonnen
wir müssen schon nachteile durch also
den ich am anfang bis zum herunterfallen
du hättest zumindest eine wenn ich noch
zwei vielleicht über 30 mitnehmen können
chefs mitnehmen können ja locker locker
ich habe es halt und nichts um mich
gegen tages wir werden keine kubot keine
angel rein gar nix ersten fall ja oder
wird angeblich dem fall aber ich werde
immer mehr tage wo ich glaube ich könnte
die 20 blog rage er übertreibt es ist
krieg stirbt
letzter gegner übrigens nicht dass er
jetzt
deswegen konnte man ja wohl echt ein
problem
ich mach das ja auch gemacht jetzt
schreibt ganz wahrgenommen
springt nicht in zweikämpfe rein wir
hatten eben einfach schon auch noch
versuchen haben leute einfach eno team
runde im dfb team und ich hab dich
beleidigt eigentlich sollte ich die
andere folge auch hochladen oder ich
oder ich zeig euch kurz die stelle
einfach weil ich dafür safe gebannt
werde zumindest ein chat nude bekomme
und so hab ich wenigstens gesehen hat
sich gelohnt
vielleicht geht also um das unternehmen
öffentlich an
es ist die leute es ist teams verboten
und sie greife sie einfach nicht an und
musste sich wahrscheinlich auch noch ich
glaub es hackt genau es ist einfach noch
team
es ist einfach notteam leute warten wir
erst mal so
jetzt komme ich ganz einfach noch ein
bisschen regen dann ist der spaß vorbei
für ihn kommt ich bin am reagan sowie
leute alles klar alles da alles klar
gott ich verweist dann wie man ihn
einmal unethischen operation und
runterhauen ja aber dies vorbei sobald
jemand schlägt
ich wollte gerade in natz sind darunter
hauen und dann lockt er mich halt weg
ich schaffe das schon nicht oder wie ich
weglaufen ist hinter mir hat einfach die
leiter gg deshalb diesem moment im leben
was ich denke jetzt nicht sein
jawohl da geht ein match jetzt gab er
aber ich habe die besten hits und
blockierte jawohl es musste der
maßnahmen